in the medieval world there were two
things body and soul the soul was the
not of the universe because it
integrated belief in God cosmology
life on Earth psychology the difference
between life and death all of those
things that started to crack with a
scientific revolution the world started
to change historian and psychiatrist
George Maharis new book is called soul
machine the invention of the modern mind
the third entity the mind started to
emerge as a natural alternative for the
place for inner life in the 1500s
notions of a secular mind were already
lurking johann vyr of holland dared to
suggest to the church fathers that not
all witches should be burned at the
stake because some of them might not
have made covenant with the devil but
just be suffering from a disease that
crippled their reasoning in the 1600s
oxford medical doctor Thomas Willis
began dissecting and mapping the brain
launching modern neuroscience in the
West and his most famous student
philosopher John Locke developed a
science-based theory of mind and of self
that said they were based partly on
imperfect subjective impressions the
mind was highly scandalous very
dangerous as an idea and was one that
very much had a lot of political and
scientific medical and theological
implications that made it quite
explosive why it challenged absolutism
both in terms of political power and in
terms of clerical power the mind was
fallible it could not make absolute
claims about truth it demanded therefore
tolerance because if I can't know the
absolute truth I should tolerate you and
you should tolerate me it allowed for
secular ethics like life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness the idea of a
center of Reason and will that was not
immortal caught on and says Macari
helped change the way the West was run
it's the centerpiece of the emergence of
secular culture but there was a problem
could you locate this new sword
mind in the brain well the brain is easy
to define I mean you can make the cut
where you want but the brain is an
empirical object the problem is interior
experience and mind is not like any
other object in the natural world
because it's not available to the
external observer and always available
to us today we have technologies that
can amaze us with new discoveries of how
some parts of the brain work and are
connected what we don't have yet I would
argue is a way of bridging mental
experience with the brain in a coherent
model that allows for mental intention
and so I would say we still are a ways
off from solving the mind brain problem
evolving concepts of mind and self
spurred by scientific explorations have
helped to change how societies are
governed basing our hopes more on the
real world the exciting question now is
whether our dazzling new technology can
help us understand what we're really
talking about when we speak of the mind
the self and even perhaps the soul